el equipo olímpico de corredores de
libertad alia
siempre ha usado los zapatos de correr
cepos pero su director deportivo
sospecha que los zapatos hartos pueden
producir mejores resultados tiempos más
bajos el director hace que seis
corredores corran dos vueltas cada uno
una usando cepos y otra usando arcos
cada corredor lanza una moneda para
determinar cuáles zapatos usará primero
el director quiere probar si sus tiempos
son significativamente más bajos cuando
usan arcos que cuando usan cepos supone
que todas las condiciones para la
diferencia se satisfacen cuál de las
siguientes opciones es la prueba y la
hipótesis alternativa más apropiada así
que su evaluación es acerca de la
hipótesis alternativa no de la nublan
pero podemos hablar de eso así que pausa
el vídeo y ver si puede resolverlo bueno
antes de pasar a este ejemplo en
particular vamos a estar seguros de que
vemos la diferencia entre una prueba de
dos muestras y una prueba de parada
cuando hablamos acerca de una prueba tv
de dos muestras o de un intervalo de dos
muestras para la diferencia entre las
medias lo que estamos haciendo es
considerar dos poblaciones y tomar dos
muestras independientes de esas
poblaciones lo que estamos tratando de
hacer es obtener estadísticas a partir
de estas muestras y tratar de estimar la
diferencia entre las medias de estas
poblaciones así que lo que está tratando
de averiguar es la diferencia de un 1
menos 2
en una situación parecida esto es muy
diferente aunque tal vez en un principio
pueda sonar igual aquí estamos viendo
una sola población y eso es exactamente
lo que está pasando en el escenario del
problema estamos tratando de averiguar
cuál es la diferencia media entre usar
zapatos cepos y hartos así que esto es a
lo que estamos tratando de llegar a la
diferencia media a es la podríamos
llamar mucho de ese post - arcos para
hacer eso tomamos una muestra y para
cada elemento de la muestra realizamos
dos mediciones una en la que corren
conceptos y otra en la que corren con
arbós después para esa muestra puedes
calcular una diferencia media entre los
cepos y los arcos hay que calcular esta
diferencia para cada elemento en la
muestra y luego sacar la media de todos
así que espero que te des cuenta de que
estas dos situaciones son muy diferentes
y cómo te puedes imaginar en este
ejemplo estamos tratando con una prueba
emparejada porque no estamos viendo dos
grupos independientes o dos muestras
independientes como lo haríamos en una
prueba tema de dos muestras así que se
trata de una prueba de parada y el
director quiere probar déjame ponerlo
con otro color si los tiempos son
significativamente más bajos cuando usan
arcos que cuando usan cepos de modo que
nuestra hipótesis nula aunque ya sé que
no nos están preguntando eso nuestra
hipótesis nula sería que no hay
diferencia que la diferencia media entre
usarse post y árbol es igual a cero
y para la hipótesis alternativa que es
en este caso lo que nos interesa bueno
si sólo estuvieran preguntando sería que
si hay una diferencia entonces diríamos
que esto no es igual a cero pero el
director quiere ver explícitamente si
los tiempos al usar arcos son
significativamente más bajos que al
usarse post así que lo que queremos ver
es si hay una evidencia que pueda
sugerir que la diferencia media de los
cepos menos los arcos sea mayor que 0 de
modo que eso sería la opción am de estas
respuestas y ya con esto hemos terminado
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo